Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono Favij è
uscito il primo Outlast nel 2013 quando
eh Praticamente ho aperto il canale ed è
stata una delle serie di maggior
successo in assoluto poi è uscito il DLC
poi è uscito il 2 nel 2023 grazie a Dio
hanno deciso di fare un'altra cosa ho
deciso di portarlo con una chicca in più
perché ho bisogno Anzi necessito di dare
a tutti voi giusto regalo per aver
aspettato tutto questo e credo che a
tutti voi me compreso faccia un sacco
piacere vederlo giocato non solo dal
fairzionale ma anche dal l'unico
inevitabile number one one
Ciao ragazzi ciao Come state Mi ha messo
un'ansia terribile già dobbiamo giocare
ad Outlast e non è proprio la cosa più
normale del mondo siamo adesso ti dovevo
fare questa intro a WWE Scusami ma io e
te in un Gameplay come quando si è vista
sta cosa raga 2 miliardi di like
dobbiamo arrivare assolutamente ragazzi
e ancora più bella è che non sappiamo
niente Cioè non sapevo niente non
l'abbiamo visto nulla raga sappiamo solo
che era in multiplayer Quindi appena ho
visto che è multiplayerho detto no
chiamo Mike subito perché qua dobbiamo
fare una cosa epocale Tre due uno e
partiamo Vai 3 3 2 1 Let's go bike
eccome è partito Eh pronto dopo la
partenza non è male
un topo impazzito sembrano le pastiglie
che prendo io per farmi crescere i
capelli No incredibile Eh io purtroppo
ormai e niente
presto le mie sopracciglia Esistono
delle pasticche per far crescere i
capelli attenzione per non farmi
ricadere In realtà io che c'ho l'ansia
eh Non stai scherzando lo faccio davvero
Purtroppo Eh no no è così intanto
L'unica cosa che afferma la caduta dei
capelli è purtroppo il pavimento quindi
sulla giusta idratarsi parlare di questo
la partenza è incredibile Ok Ah vedi se
sei solo sei povero eh Ti vogliamo
questo è facilmente in testa sicuramente
e forse era un barbone che ha trovato Ah
sì certo ha trovato l'annuncio così eh È
finito qua
dovrei essere qua ok
cioè loro reclutavano gente per strada
così per andare a fare questa cosa
simpatica e comunque tu hai scelto il
gioco giusto per la monetizzazione Sì
infatti io io a me non mi piace
monetizzare su YouTube non so se si è
capito questa cosa Eh da un sacco di
tempo eh questi casi ci metto anche una
canzone copyritata facciamo prima
questa era quello che ha preso il
volantino non mi pare no
Ah ecco beh Perfetto
direi demonetizzato subito e così ci
passa il pensiero però signorina è
carina però guarda guarda utilizzano le
mascherine e la cuffietta verde
giustamente la prima cosa mi sembra
giusto
Questa l'ha messo nel naso nell'occhio
dovrò mettere Non voglio saperlo
comunque però sono tuo amico ti aiuterò
perfetto Secondo me è il benacol quello
eh non è che sì sì è quello della gola
Beh ragazzi non saprei neanche come
commentare ma che c'aveva una maschera
gliela tolta Non ho capito E lui senza
mascherina sta roba e infatti lui non
gliene frega niente
[Musica]
Ah mi Ficca la mamma no ma almeno
pulitela che schifo ci hanno messo la
maschera di quello che è morto di fianco
ma guarda che non tutto il male vien per
nuocere È vero È vero È vero magari
Vabbè Vabbè comunque è successo ragazzi
perfetto Non stiamo giocando a Peppa Pig
quello sarà capito però insomma la
maschera Comunque a me farebbe schifo Io
so germofobico non lo so te
non me le metterei queste cose ci
svegliamo Vai 3 2 1 Vai yeah Speriamo
insieme e ci svegliamo insieme poi ci
uniremo alla partita ragazzi non so come
non so quando è perché tu cacchio siamo
ma scusa ma noi non siamo quelli che ci
hanno ficcato la maschera prima oppure
era un'altra cosa quella Forse era una
roba randomica Ci ha fatto vedere cos'è
questo complesso Eh però noi siamo altri
Ah dai è vero forse sì ci abbiamo il
visore notturno vedi Sì sì l'ho visto
l'ho visto con la F Questo è il classico
di Outlast ragazzi apro la porta
dell'emploise che è bloccata niente
quindi bisogna andare dall'altra parte
però ci siamo svegliati qua per quale
motivo Scusami è più che altro ci hanno
buttato proprio nel cassonetto Sì esatto
è stata terribile sta cosa non ti
preoccupare A meno che L'obiettivo non è
sopravvivere Comunque raga io c'ho un
problema cioè Lazio C'ho l'ansia Qua c'è
scritto elimina il tuo passato
boh dipende se sono dieci anni di
YouTube sei con me ti sei fatto il culo
quadro magari non eliminiamo Però magari
c'è qualcosa di strano che hai fatto
cose giuste sbagliate si fa gli
scheletri nell'armadio quelle cose là
fuori scheletri sicuramente ce ne
saranno Oh buongiorno c'è una tipa al
vetro bella stazia Salve La vedo bella
sveglia ma che è un manichino Ma cos'è
una persona non ti dice la casa ci sono
dei corpi davanti che invogliano ad
entrare qua Bello questo infatti devo
dire devo dire Ti devo dire è abbastanza
accogliente Sì è bello ma non ci credo
Esatto ma neanche ci passa Ah sì sono
manichini Vedi c'è uno che Ecco ti do il
bentornato a casa ma guarda stavo bene
dove stavo Prima effettivamente amore
amore
Ma cacchio adesso il manichino ha delle
mani giganti è terrificante Sì esatto
MasterChef Porca [__] Ecco non è
strana questa stanza c'è un chitaia ti
devi liberare da sto qua c'è un davvero
grosso Allora questa era una tattica
Ragazzi ho mandato avanti lui è bravo
Hai fatto bene intanto mi ha detto sotto
c'era scritto è stata un'azione di merda
ah aveva scritto proprio sotto Grazie
grazie! Sì ma guarda che quando
giochiamo insieme non te le faccio
queste cose Vai avanti pure non ho
capito Ah ti fa curare dopo di far sì
Meno male Ragazzi ho preso degli
schiaffi importanti quindi Menomale hai
capito cosa cisti bibitoni ma non
chiedere va bene porte aperte a pedate
okay okay okay però adesso a pedate Oh
sono in teatro ma non state a guardare
nei Ragazzi c'è il teatro potete
guardare tranquillamente Ah c'è una mela
c'è una mela la prendiamo altre 3 2 1
Let's go
bella Bella bona Mela Verde No ecco lo
sapete come pesce fresco È una mela
Questa non è questa roba cioè guarda
guarda eh eh sempre sul tizio che lo
muove il trapano e lo vendono da Brico
Questo è un trapano simpatico
Eh infatti ho intenzione Ah vuole
sostituire le parti marce ma io me la
cavo abbastanza bene Ahia Porca vacca
questa ha fatto male questo ha fatto
male Però vabbè però eh maniputate mani
bucate ci sta bene Esatto esatto
Attenzione C'è un tizio Penso sia il
primo nemico Se sei al buio resta in
silenzio molti nemici non ti troveranno
principe per accorciarti non far rumore
qua c'è la parte che devi nasconderti ok
ok sì C'è un tizio qua attenzione Ah c'è
pure una bocciare quello spadone eh c'ha
lo spadone eh Cioè nel senso che c'ha
siringa o C'ha proprio la spada non l'ho
vista io eh eh potrebbe avere tutti e
due di sto gioco eh No c'ha Machete No
no vai Apri la porta Aprila piano che se
no Ok l'ho passato l'ho passato Ah mo
vedi c'ha aperto la scala Ok arrivo eh
quindi si può andare Ti aspetto però c'è
una musica Ah no no ti aspetto al quale
corre Oh non ti aspetto ad andare sopra
vai Che quello sta correndo Arrivo
arrivo chiusa la porta [__] Meno
male Minchia c'era il tizio che che mi
sta seguendo non era proprio il massimo
aspettarti Ah c'è l'uscita mi sa che è
finito il tutorial eh Vedo una signora
che sta per mettere un tipo dentro ah ah
Ah aspe è vero Anch'io adesso sono
entrato e prima non ero entrato e non mi
sbaglio adesso mi sperava lì che succede
perché
ragazzi così fa si fa la carne tritata
la faceva così anche Jeffrey Dame Ma sta
gente Dove la pigliano perché finisce
qua eh Eh io non so se voglio vedere
questa scena Ragazzi questa Esatto Non
vorrei vedere questa scena Ah però vedo
che tanto comunque il gioco sarà
esplicito tutto quindi inutile che mi
giro perché in un'altra scuola normale
mi ricordo che mi giravo per non far
vedere qualcosa in realtà ormai tutto il
gioco è così quindi che devo fare adesso
era Giampiero Giampiero censura tu eh
che io non voglio fare sta vita
bene Questo è quello che provo io quando
faccio 10 piegamenti in palestra
comunque la stessa cosa
Buongiorno
ma non sono proprio sicuro signora sei
traumatizzato che non ti sento più eh Ma
l'abbiamo perso raga' Mike è
traumatizzato ci sta è saltata la
corrente Vi prego ore è saltata la
corrente Metti in pausa Porcaccia
eccoti qua No guarda so' senza parole
davvero non ti preoccupare
vai qua porca [__] Ok tira le parole ce
l'ho fatta [__] Non è vero non ce l'ho
fatta a rivederci sto facendo schifo te
lo dico
dentro
Chiuditi si è chiuso vai Lone che faccio
schifo per te Beh sì credo che sia la
fine del tutorial ragazzi mi hanno
rimandato nel dormitorio Vediamo che
succede Allora tu prova a fare Skip
tutorial Mike Vediamo se non riesco a
entrare allora Mike ha avviato una
partita Mi dice Cioè il bagnetto di
quello che c'è negli Acquapark prima di
entrare in piscina ragazzi molto
divertente Spero che non ci sia la
piscina qua mikeshow io ti vedo Ah io ti
vedo ti vedo sulla mappa e tu sei di
sopra eh Sei di sopra come faccio a
arrivare di sopra Dai vengo di sopra
Vediamo Ah questa stanno giocando a
braccio di ferro c'è altra gente Ma che
cacchio è vengo da te Aspetta che arrivo
Ecco ti sei qua eh Eccoti ah
ah sei Brian May secondo dei Queen Ma
che è quella cos'è Beh ho cercato ho
pensato entro nella testa di un killer
cioè sono talmente bravi che cosi Eh
forse no se sei più grosso e loro non
sei terribile cioè i capelli veramente
ci sediamo qua vediamo se riusciamo a
fare Braccio di Ferro Io e te ma questo
lo volevo comprare non ha capito che
doveva giocare no Vieni vieni che
facciamo Braccio di Ferro 3 2 1 3 e poi
arriva colpisci l'aria Oh che è
Aspetta ma quella rossa dobbiamo colpire
quella rossa Eh non lo so vediamo Io
sono bravissimo io abbracciati dal vivo
perderei tantissimo ma a quanto pare
sono bravissimo Mike lo so non so come
sia possibile come sono un fenomeno
Favij è finito un fenomeno e no no no
voglio le vittorie Cioè non lo sapevi
mai rifare Sì sì adesso sì sì e lo
rifacciamo non so come ho fatto a fare
sta cosa rosso dobbiamo spingere da solo
un fenomeno Cioè veramente no ok e forse
qua vi sta vincendo tu mi sa Eh no
attenzione Comunque tu e non lo so
perché sto prendendo più pallini io però
attenzione
fermo fermo loro Noi dobbiamo ottenere
10 gettoni per essere per andarcene da
qui ok Quindi è un gioco a Dobbiamo
ottenere le cose per andare avanti
Quindi abbiamo bisogno di fare questi
trials E vabbè facciamo le triie va bene
Allora ragazzi e usciamo così io credo
che ogni prova sarà un gettone un
gettone Allora andiamo a fare il trovare
i cosi andiamo usa il terminale E certo
allora test ricerca gruppo ma va bene
anche così Per iniziare un percorso di
miglioramento sembrava tipo quelli lì
agli alcolisti anonimi non è la stessa
cosa Eh faceva un programma Uno mi sa
che quello che faccio io ti fa fare a te
via la camera di esecuzione e poi infine
alle sue menzogne
Ok questo dobbiamo fare va bene Avvia
capito Vabbè facciamo in due facciamo in
due Uccidi la spia Oh occhio ci spara
quello Eh no è finto Aspè Forse posso
rubargli la pistola tipo No ma ci sono
le pistole in questo gioco forse ci sono
le pistole perché negli altri outlet non
c'erano Eh
questo è un tizio che l'hanno buttato se
mettessero la pistola in Outlast Infatti
Dove possiamo distruggere Ah eccoti
siamo sicuri
che ci si può nascondere Ah vuoi andare
avanti andiamo avanti Ma cos'è secondo
Annamo tutto Vai vai FPS
non lo vedo no te lo giuro lo vedi che
ti Pingo no Sì certo Buongiorno Ahia
[__]
Aspetta aspetta eh vabbè niente Non sono
riuscito
Allora noi dobbiamo uccidere una spia
che sia con la tizia Eh
non lo so Porca vacca ma stai attenta
c'è qualcuno qua sento che urlano
praticamente c'è un tizio Mike C'è un
tizio alla tua sinistra c'è un tizio
Meno male che ero entrato Ah Eccolo
eccolo Aspetta io io mi nascondo qua
rieletto arrangiati porco Giuda mi ha
tirato un destro Okay okay Vabbè ma tu
non lo voglio fuori non lo voglio vedere
Eh no anzi no è entrato ti seguo e mi sa
che il tronco qua
aiuto Dammi una mano è difficile Porca
[__] Mike Aiuto dove sei È sempre qua
davanti Vabbè Eh l'ho chiuso Mi ha fatto
malissimo io vorrei fuggire Ma non
riesco mi ha fatto malissimo in stazione
polizia hai mai Aiutami aiutami Chiuditi
Aspetta aspetta
Io ho visto una scena e ho visto una
scena che non vorrei mai rivedere
ho visto uno che ti si è lanciato sul
naso È stato terribile Oddio Ma perché
Che tempismo di merda che c'ho Ok Eccoti
qua eh Faccio il giro in realtà ce l'ha
lui va bene va bene questo qua per
lanciarlo Ok prendi questo medico dov'è
vede' Questa è un medikit questa Ah
minchia pensavo sei bottiglie per
distrarre la gente io ho Ok Qua c'è una
mina io non ci andrei di sopra per non
sapere niente Sai non non ce n'era un
casino col vetro Eh questo è vero se
attiriamo il tizio sulla Mina che
succede Eh vabbè Quello non lo so Vabbè
comunque entriamo nella Security Room
Perché dobbiamo aprire sta porta però
per passare di qua come passiamo Ah
dalla scrivania Aspetta aspetta che ce
ne sono diversi Eh ma non è che la
possiamo raccogliere quella Mina Ma io
vai tu vai tu però tu
[__] Oh ma che palle Ma perché
puoi andare in giro ok Stiamo passando
sulla Mina Gli ho tirato una bomba Oh
questo Magic non devo co quello
lanciarvi eh È pieno di trappole Ma no
ragazzi facciamo ridere questo gioco
comunque tutti e due tra me e te non è
che è incredibile
ma non riesco perché c'è uno ce l'ho
dietro proprio
aiuto Ahia m'ha urlato in faccia Madonna
Comunque vado C'è gente che rompe le
palle se n'è andato però se n'è andato
eh C'è questo qua ancora gran manganello
No io andrei Via Vai via scappa scappa
vai Vieni vieni vieni vieni vieni vieni
corri corri andiamo andiamo andiamo eh
nella Security Room A me non mi corre
più perché ho preso le testate
Madonna Raga ma è terribile cioè
veramente non si può fare niente che che
ci fosse tanta gente è stato terribile
vuoi riprendere il tasto premo io faccio
io che ogni 5 di voler fare questa cosa
vediamo
tutto questo per un per un punto perché
ce ne servono 10 per uscire da qualcosa
no
il tizio quello che si stava alle
manganellate lì minchia
Oh Oh minchia ragazzi
Beh ma io non so perché è scritto gioco
sono tutti incazzati se ci pensi non è
normale ma stai calmo No Stai calmo
quest'uomo è sotto la mia protezione se
fotti lui sta parlando di di chi sta
parlando Ah fammi uscire non so Vabbè eh
ah ah ah della spia Ok holdings Eccoli
qua di qua
di qua Vedi che qua c'è una siringa
abbiamo bisogno Ah per rianimare gli
amici ti posso rianimare se muori
no E credo che sia per quello Questo
invece è una bottiglia che posso tirare
in testa a qualcuno che non è male
questo perché c'è anche qualcuno che
piange c'è qualcuno Eccolo qua Guarda
questa è la spia la spia Chiedi al
proprio avvocato Ecco È vero è vero
non vogliamo sapere cosa sia successo
qua c'è la spia Guarda eh Allora la
dobbiamo fare fuori
Aspetta c'è scritto Snitch che puzza di
Snitch Eh vabbè allora la la la la la
pasticciata Ah mi sa che è tipo il
carico di overwatch devi devi Oddio che
è successo Perché le luci
ne nascondo a prescindere va senza
saperne leggere né scrivere Arrivederci
nel seminterrato Io mi sono nascosto
Mike c'ho paura No ma che si sospetti Io
mi sono cagato addosso a prescindere
precauzione fatto bene fatto bene Sei
qua Snitch che arriviamo
ma qua è l'uscita di nuovo Allora forse
dobbiamo andare nel parcheggio
Underground parking Eccolo qua
vorrei picchiarlo ogni volta che apri
qualcosa devi stare attento perché li
lascia una trappola questo lo apro col
grimaldello Va bene Vediamo che c'è
qui ci sarà io io a sbloccare le cose
Ragazzi mi sono allenato prima con
Braccio di Ferro Uh due medkit va bene
prendiamo una testa dai mamma mia quanto
sei altruista ragazzi
Dobbiamo sollevarlo in due non fai tipo
The Last of Us si può sì
perfetto Vai prova a vedere È come
faccio a tempo vai vai vai Mamma mia
ragazzi Mamma mia che giocatore È
incredibile giochi di videogiochi al
generatore sta qui Oh che è successo C'è
qualcuno
io non lo vedo mi do nascondere
io lo attiro e tu pulisci Bravo bravo
Vabbè però dai Allora aspetta eh C'è una
tanica lì a destra volendo l'idiota se
n'è andato da solo Vabbè dai vai vai
è un nemico di mai che l'antagonista di
Mike tipo la versione malvagia tipo il
givav frequentare Favij è veramente Ma
chi era Non lo so Ragazzi cosa Appena
succede meno male che l'ho registrata ce
l'ho documentata sta cosa hai visto
riempiendo intanto Eh sto sto creando il
lavoro sporco Ma guarda il generatore è
qua l'abbiamo rifatto che ce ne sta
un'altra magari ce n'è un altro perché
qua vedo che c'è un'altra tanica in mano
Quindi immagino ci sia altra roba vieni
qua Allora su Instagram Ahia [__]
sono quasi morto Porca [__] C'era un
coso per terra Mi ha fatto malissimo ma
di un male incredibile
tu stai impazzendo c'era il gas
psicologico
a te allora sono stronzo io T'ho trovato
qui raccogli Non lo so non sono andato
perché mi sono fatto malissimo Eh c'è il
tipo entrato è entrato lo distratto ce
l'ho fatta
c'è il mikeshowsha cattivo ok
non vedo nulla Raga ma niente Cioè non
so come scappare Non vedo
Ok
sei riuscito a scappare Io sono
scappando Cioè abbiamo fatto ragazzi
l'importante è quello Allora dove la
spia Vai vai sollevo passi Giusto giusto
Vieni vieni vieni vieni passa vai vai
vai vai giù così due gusti meglio che
vuoi vado io prima che arrivi gente che
già la sento che parla ma lasciami
indietro non pensare mai corri e basta
ce l'abbiamo fatta
Porco Dio non t'azzardato che ormai
bastardo Ma che poi stavo fuori l'ho
picchiato Io sto con uno sputazzo di
vita Io sto continuando a menare al
tizio Eh vabbè spingi spingi ma tutto
sto casino per spingere questo qua
c'è un miliardo di Modi per far fuori la
gente qua dobbiamo spingerlo su stadia
qualcuno mi spiegherà la trama nei
commenti ce la spiegava che io non trova
la chiave Ciao Ah dobbiamo aprire sta
porta Adesso pure la chiave è mancante
Però possiamo provare a fare così alla
tv per trovare gli indizista la TV
chiave fuoco chiave fuoco l'avevo letto
mare fuori io cosa vuol dire chiaro ce
la porta c'è scritto chiave più che più
che di questo chiavi in mano sì chiave
chiave in mano chiave nel cuore ecco
questa è roba tua eh Vedi Io non ne
voglio sapere Oh ma questo va avanti
intanto per il bello del Gameplay lo
devi fare te eh No io non mi fa schifo
Non è che posso Poi con le mani Ecco le
mani con le mani manco con le mani con
le mani con le mani squartiamo Ecco qua
paio di preservata E drorata sì c'è la
chiave molto la vuoi che è pulita ma
tanto indossavo la mascherina eh Sei
troppo forte ok A posto siamo
per le mani Sì no E non ho finito
l'amuchina Trova le altre chiavi a
quante chiavi dobbiamo trovare noi qua
qua mi sa che dobbiamo trovare altra
roba perché vedo che ci sono un sacco di
porte mi porto avanti sfondandole
vediamo Io Sento rumori molestiche
Certamente
scorciatoia scorciatoia Vabbè ciao Vai
c'è gente c'è gente veloci Ok vai
nasconditi da qualche parte non so dove
non so neanche chi c'è però in realtà a
prescindere
Mi sa che il momento sbagliato eh forse
morirò Oddio C'è uno nudo grosso col
pisello di fuori eh Io mi sono nascosto
Qua c'è un altro cadavere volendo Mmm A
me non m'ha trovato alla chiave coniglio
abbiamo preso il via Secondo me abbiamo
capito bene come dire Io però sto tipo
ai calcio forte oddio oddio cadavere
errato anzi mi ha dato pure la scossa
Sto stronzo eh no mi hai preso
ti ha preso il tizio eh Oh merda stai
dissanguando Eh sì io stavo proprio
sotto le palle in questo momento eh Non
so se riesco a prenderlo Aspetta eh che
mo' Eccoti vai
un compagno mi sta aiutando ho appreso
facciamo il giro dall'altra parte Vieni
vieni con me la Girola dove sono
arrivato
e il tizio è veramente brutto
Ho preso un'altra chiave
Questi stanno facendo Mike Guarda un
attimo che io non capisco
[Musica]
bene
Ahia
Ma che è successo
Sì chiave visto la chiave perfetto
perfetto perfetto perfetto perfetto
perfetto perfetto perfetto Aspetta ho
trovato queste picche hai trovato te lo
dico subito sì Vai perfetto perfetto
abbiamo tutte le chiavi dove dobbiamo
tornare ehm no con due abbiamo le chiavi
Eh però non so dove dobbiamo andare e
dobbiamo dove stava l'infamia
Eccola switch puzza di Snitch Comunque
trasportarci
veramente molto facilmente molto più
facile Oh più che altro che ho due pugni
da qua Eh si danza a te
il piselloide Tra l'altro Questo è il
nuovo nome il piselloide Tra l'altro
Oh fratello Google
Ciao Mike Ciao ciao
scusa scusa scusa Mike Come stai C'è un
mio amico qua porca [__] Eh se me fai
tu vai
Io speriamo che non passi qua sotto
perché sennò
non c'è passato non c'è passato
ok Stiamo andando vai Io vorrei provare
a difenderti lanciandogli qualcosa sto
dicendo Mamma mia vai vai vai vai vai
Madonna che brutto Comunque ragazzi
veramente brutti sta arrivando io li
lancio la bottiglia no c'è un altro c'è
un altro tizio
Mannaggia chi t'è muort eh perfetto Però
il problema è che sta arrivando lo
stesso Mike te lo tiro via io vai vai
vai vai vai Allora proprio non gliene
vuole sapere di me perché stanno dai
Mike Attenzione è perché non riesco
addosso Ah io non spingo
no Favij No non è Favij Favij
Ecco Oddio Favij eh aiuto eh Apri la
porta Vai CAP Apri la porta Io corro
Apri la porta Dov'è la porta Ali ma che
ne so No vabbè ragazzi è terribile Ma
chi è Vincenzo Favij è il cattivo di
Favij è un altro suo ultimo metro da
fare è impossibile comunque perché ci
pensa spengo la spia ce l'hai fatta ce
l'ho messo dentro Fulgor alla spia però
ci sta il poliziotto Amo guarda ci sono
poi
Oh merda lo devi tenere premuto guarda
Uno lo tira e l'altro Vai allora io sto
folgorando poi vai vai vai Mi sta
seguendo a me sta seguendo Sì
lo porto via
vai volgono
un gioco da ragazzi Ah mi sono chiusa
dentro con Ahia che male va tira Non
pensare a me vai sto girando più forte
che posso No sei morto Vai a me Io non
ho non so come hai fatto a resistere
all'esecuzione perché a me come mi
ammazzano quindi
funzionano 71 75 vai vai vai vai
resistono sacrificato per mi sono
sacrificato per la causa va bene Io
veramente io ragazzi
No non ci credo No non ci credo
sei morto a 99
Che merda ragazzi Ti prego
fallimento
99%. Sì credo ma veramente non ho fatto
in tempo neanche a vedere
ma incredibile Questa cosa No vabbè
ragazzi era 99% ve lo giuro o forse 98
viaggio ma Quindi cosa vuol dire che
mica ce la faranno rifare One Hit Energy
Daniel
ci abbiamo messo una vita quindi dovevo
sfogarmi andiamo via io sono quasi
arrivato
ci fai mano mano ok No no cioè sono
entrato dalla tua entrata Ormai in
questa ribattezzata l'entrata di Mike Oh
ma il tipo nude
qua Oh ma che cazzo ci fa qua attenzione
via via via via via via via via via via
via questa porta di merda Apri
bile l'arrivo della navetta questi son
scemi minchia Gli ho tirato un mattone
in bocca Corri corri che forse c'è una
navetta è arrivata vediamo
È arrivata corri mai cioè ci sto corri
corri corri
Eh madonna non ho capito perché ti serve
mi devo prendere pure io quel robo per
la sanità mentale
[Musica]